we have why he's leaving no no we have
this we have
the briefcase yeah the briefings again
yes we was the lady who brought it in
because nobody well we don't need the
big wall yeah
so
we enjoyed that so while the starters
are voted on by the fans and players and
media
coaches vote for the reserves they vote
in their own conference can't vote for
your own guys
but before we open the briefcase
let's bring the newest member of our
crew in draymond green joins us from san
francisco draymond three-time all-star
this is a it's gonna be a very exciting
night for the 14 guys who have their
names called tonight man
uh absolutely i
this week in waiting from reserve i mean
from starter to reserve is always a long
time i'm excited to to find out who the
all-star reserves are tonight hopefully
this won't be like a draft process for
me where i'm sitting here sitting here
and then i'm not a reserve so we'll see
i'm pretty sure we got you on tv you
made the team but no not necessarily no
we don't know no
it's a sealed box there's no way he's
not gonna be how do we know that because
nobody wouldn't had him on tv
let me tell you something if you don't
make the team quit on the spot that'll
be good tv all right so let's go eastern
first no we're going we're going west
we're going west first we had and
they're all in individual
envelopes yes so here's our first
draymond western conference
reserve that's it devin booker yes nice
yes well deserved absolutely
yeah first all-star selection in his
seventh season
giving the suns 25 a game
uh that's number 13 in the league five
rebounds four assists 15 games of at
least 30 a couple of 40-point games had
48 against san antonio so
devin booker
is an all-star yes are these in any
particular years there are no particular
envelopes
not only that
does it taste like chicken
from the dallas mavericks luca dante
there you go
really really solid
fourth straight all-star appearance in
his fourth season
tied for eighth with steph curry in
points per game he's got 26 a night nine
rebounds he's fifth of the vegan assists
he's got seven triple doubles
nine games of at least 30 points
he of course the 2019
rookie of the year so luka doncic and
devin booker so far um
shaq ernie where's my envelope do i get
the open one uh i wish you could i wish
there's a way we could do that but here
is number three
from the utah jazz rudy gobert oh yes
rudy making his third straight all-star
appearance in his ninth season
16 points a game he leads the league in
rebounds with 15.
he's had 22 games
15 rebounds
six games of at least 20 for the
reigning defensive player
of the year so rudy gobert
is on there with luka doncic and devin
booker which you had in this to uh
chuckster no
i mean that boy first of all
all right
my new bff from the golden state
warriors draymond green
all right
god give us some space
okay oh well this would be his fourth uh
appearance
eight points eight rebounds seven
assists i know when they became dff
kenny 54 from the field
got a triple double this year for the
golden state warriors who with a record
of 39 and 13 after second best record in
the western conference congratulations
everyone thank you thank you oh man
people around here yelling they must be
on a tape delay yeah yeah
exactly right yeah that's what i'm
saying draymond no one knew actually you
know and please stop it kenny
they're opening their envelopes on tv no
one knows you think we would have had
him on if he wasn't going to make the
changes good point just stop it good
point chuck come on i think it was
important chuck i i don't think they
knew i was i just had to come on and
perform my duties dre trust me we're not
that cruel around here all right are we
ready
for number five yes
from the utah jazz donovan mitchell
okay donovan mitchell
his third all-star selection
third straight in his fifth season
uh 25 points a game is number 12 in the
league four rebounds five assists
shooting 45
13 games of at least 30.
for the 2018 slam dunk champion wow this
is where it gets interesting donovan
mitchell is in i think it's been
interesting all day yeah no no but those
guys were locks all right uh not
necessarily well let's let's get to
these last two envelopes kenny would you
be so kind oh you're going to give me
another one yeah thank you sir
wow this is a shocker right here
no it's not
from the phoenix suns chris paul
12.
league leader in assists also 15 points
a game four rebounds he's had 14 games
with at least 13 assists including the
season high of 19 against the spurs so
chris paul joins his teammate devin
booker from the phoenix suns as wow now
this is going to be this is the final
western conference reserve well thank
you sir certainly thank you from the
minnesota timberwolves stop now chuck
straight just guessing
you're tripping dejante murray
shaq
from the minnesota timberwolves
call anthony townsend carl anthony towns
third time he's been an all-star in his
seventh season first time since 2019
24 points a game
nine rebounds four assists ranks in the
top 20 of scoring rebounding and
three-point percentage
with 10 games of at least 30 points for
the 26 and 25 minnesota timberwolves and
so there are your seven
reserves okay from the western
conference